en octubre de 2001 el gobierno de eeuu
con george w.bush a la cabeza anunció el
inicio de la guerra contra el terrorismo
que se libraría fuera de las fronteras
estadounidenses
ediciones de este mail en el conflicto
de gas natural
fenosa por mentes pases diarios en
colores de ver acciones de ge para
calmar los temores de los seals en negó
take the long líneas de tren un perro
es una pasión
el trajín del país
entero
días después una coalición internacional
liderada por washington invadió
afganistán para derrocar al grupo
talibán al que acusaba de proteger a
osama bin laden y a otros jefes de al
qaeda los talibanes que tomaron el poder
después de una ocupación soviética se
negaron a entregarlos el grupo huyó de
kabul hacia pakistán
en diciembre de ese mismo año la casa
blanca- publica este vídeo en el que
osama bin laden asume la autoridad de
los ataques del 11 de septiembre
para nuestro mundo
meses después bus también incluyó a irak
en su eje del mal y acusó a saddam
hussein de tener vínculos con al-qaeda y
armas de destrucción masiva
eeuu invadió a irak y derrocó a hussein
pero el armamento nuclear nunca fue
hallado y se dio paso a un conflicto
entre las fuerzas iraquíes y los
insurgentes que devinieron con los años
en el autodenominado estado islámico el
14 al qaeda se desligó de ellos en un
comunicado en paralelo la cia lleva a
cabo una cacería de 10 años que según un
informe del senado estadounidense
utilizó actos de tortura como
ahogamiento simulado aislamiento extremo
y privación del sueño en guantánamo y
otros centros de detención para obtener
información que rindieron fruto en la
noche del primero al 2 de mayo de 2011
cuando dos helicópteros despegaron desde
afganistán hacia el norte de pakistán
con 23 integrantes de la unidad de
fuerzas especiales
desde la sala de crisis de la casa
blanca bajo la administración obama se
vivieron momentos de tensión que
quedarán para la historia en esta foto
es night like in recorte de tipos entre
the world ordinario state se les
contactó en una versión de bild usamos
vengan del iderbol cairo
además de bienes en mente
osama bin laden fue identificado con
pruebas de adn y software de
reconocimiento facial sus restos fueron
arrojados al mar sin dejar rastro para
evitar que se convirtiera en santuario
de extremistas
dos años después en 2013 el fundador del
grupo talibán mulá omar murió en un
hospital de karachi la otan finalizó su
misión en afganistán en diciembre de
2014 pero mantuvo 13.000 soldados para
apoyar los operativos antiterroristas
en 2015 el grupo talibán inicia una
serie de ataques con coches bomba y para
2020 bajo la administración de donald
trump firma un acuerdo de paz en doha
qatar en el que se acuerde retirar todas
las tropas extranjeras en 14 meses el 31
de agosto de 2021 si se mantiene el cese
de hostilidades en mayo de 2021 los
talibanes comienzan un operativo de
retoma que llega a su punto máximo para
el 15 de agosto cuando cae kabul miles
de personas se aglomeraron en el
aeropuerto de la capital afgana buscando
huir ante el temor de que el regreso del
talibán traerá consigo una aplicación
extrema de la sharía la ley islámica
haciendo retroceder los derechos ganados
en 20 años por niños y mujeres
especialmente aún así el presidente joe
by the incompleto y defendió su retirada
argumentando que la misión había sido
cumplida